what it means to them
every farmer needs to know his number we
need 25 of knowing their number by the
end of this year every farmer needs to
know the emissions profile by the end of
2022
and they will be working out the pricing
mechanisms by 2025 we'll start writing
out the chicks or whatever by then
um
climate change got some other challenges
too opportunities for southland you know
we talk about that 75 70
agriculture generating the export
revenues
the new world is is a green energy world
as a green tech world as a what are our
opportunities there what are some of the
comparative advantages that south and or
gore has got there currently we sit
there with a um
with the energy generation source it's
provisioning 14 of new zealand's energy
at the moment and this the government is
currently saying well what are we going
to do with that in the future is it is
it appropriate that the state is being
used at its current source or if you
wanted to transition to a clean green
economy what would you be using that 14
of new zealand's renewable energy for
what are our other opportunities here
with their wooden resources and their
water resources in southland for
electricity green electricity generation
and they see some of the periphery
advantages there we don't have a great
population
that will be saying well don't put that
one generator near me
because i don't want to see it
but you know as i say it's kind of one
of those sort of periphery opportunities
that we should be considering
climate change adds some other
challenges too um i encourage you guys
to read this latest water availability
and security now taya rao report just
released about a week after mpi
this report validates that a temperature
climate in new zealand has increased by
one degree in the past hundred years
and is challenged or has modeled to move
another 0.5 to 1 degree by 2040
on all the tracks of climate change
reduction
it's also modeled now it's also
validated that where national rainfall
is reduced by 10 percent
they do it in five-year ban so get hold
of this since 1996 i think was the
five-year ban
really
visual in some regions you know they've
done all the regions in new zealand
so
three take-home messages climate's
increased going to keep going for a bit
longer till we get this sorted out a
rainfall stability has variable you'll
see it changes but on a mass on on
balance it's coming down
we've got to start considering what we
do to provision for our communities
for water storage and water security
the other flip side of that is the third
part of that stool is um
the rainfall events we're having now are
coming slightly more sporadically and
more in slightly extreme events like we
witnessed in february was it recently
last year yep now
you'll be well aware that you guys are
probably standing on the flood banks
wondering if this is going to go to 2500
qmix or because the flood banks are
designed for 2400 qmix
now if we're going to experience that
what's the stuff we should start talking
about as a community should we build
bigger walls
you only have to go up on a plane and
you'll see that you know gore intersects
in the southern geocline it's a
bottleneck here
this community you know what's the cost
of flooding this community
flooding material flooding windom versus
making some intervention intervention
steps
that might look along the lines of
water security
catchment
and integrating nutrient reductions um
integrating water security integrating
all these sort of challenges we've got
so that's just like sort of just i want
to challenge you guys on that like
the cost of flooding a town and the risk
of it like we saw over on the west coast
it's just too great these days we've got
to start looking at alternative
solutions so it's an mpi report yeah
yeah so this is on on the website this
is a really good report because this is
so we're working with a group called the
food and fiber partnership group and
we're strategizing for the ag sector
around all the things we need to start
reprovisioning in light of a new uh some
of these challenges
um you'll be well aware the discussions
going on and south and two around um so
we've got i always draw three circles
i'm having these discussions it's carbon
water biodiversity these are the three
sort of olympic circles of the
sustainability debate
and if we actually get in there and we
sort of sort so the the carbon issue
make the same decisions that you know
riparian management integration of trees
into her properties
integration of biodiversity the
solutions are all doable and intersect
but these are the discussions we all
have to have as a community
please get close to what environment
south is telling us at the moment
there's going to be some significant
nutrient reductions in the southland
economy when we are so reliant on
agriculture
i think it would be well worth being
cognizant of what impacts that might
have there
um
well just some of the other things that
i think you should be thinking about and
considering isn't in that sustainability
debate too one of the conversations
we're having
nationally is access to capital
um it's this is a bit like the esg
environmental social governance debate
um
we don't want to become the tobacco
industry
of
that's not what we want to be so in the
sustainability debates to protect their
communities we want to reprovision
ourselves that people actually we report
on their sustainability their ghg
metrics their impact on waters
impact on biodiversities so we can
access that capital to make this
reprovisioning
um
finally look this isn't all doom and
gloom there's a bunch of people working
on solutions in here you know that
methane debate you know we're working a
pastoral greenhouse gas research
consortium since 2003 we've been working
on
vaccines inhibitors to you know to solve
the uh the methane risk profile for
agricultural sector
the other big thing i haven't called out
you know when i talk about the
agricultural sector wall has been one of
the
it's one of the problem commodities
we're dealing with at the moment but
there's a bunch of work being done on
that at the moment just to finish up
i've been making five statements to our
farming community recently um
there's no sector in new zealand bar
none that's had the productivity gains
that the sheep and beef sectors had in
the past 30 years there's no there's not
there's none none can match it it's done
a piece of work at beef and lamb it's
been the most profitable decade in 60
years for a sector
um
you've never had x cheaper access to
capital in the agricultural sector or in
new zealand previously so in
reprovisioning for a lot of these
challenges you've never had cheaper
access to capital
and the global demand for your product
has never been stronger
so those are four things and then the uh
no i won't say the no i will say the
fifth thing and then the fifth thing if
you're getting really grumpy about this
stuff and you don't believe me and you
want to sell your farm you'll probably
get a pretty strong record price for at
the moment
so
the point being is look i listed a bunch
of challenges there at risk but these
are all things we've got to think about
as a community and how we start
reprovisioning and solve these problems
so that we can create wealth and
prosperity for our community
sorry i've raced through that pretty
quickly
i think you've done very well there
poured a lot of information out onto the
floor there now we're going to try and
put it into piles
um
i know you're on a time constraint there
but is
any questions there or any discussion
from the councillors
any further discussion
i'd just like to ask the question if i
may mr chair um given the fact that lamb
numbers have been so low
how do you see your group working to
increase that what's going on in your
sector
well it's slightly almost a
misconception so we've we've halved
their u numbers by about 50 percent but
our lamb numbers are only eight percent
down or are there kilograms of product
we sell and that goes to the point
there's no sectors have the productivity
gains so look at the size of a sector is
not judged by its size it's judged by
the wealth that it creates
and so that's why i say i'm agnostic to
land use change but i want our land use
change to be linked to market rather
than regulatory drivers
and and going forward how do you see
your group working to produce what
consumers want
yeah well we've done a bunch of
provisioning in there you know and this
goes back to that sustainability debate
we've done we've initiated a program you
know government talks a a program of uh
volume to value so we identified we did
a big market research piece we've
identified that you know we're i'll use
a technical term we're a deadly squat
protein producer globally we're two
percent of sheep meats globally two
percent of protein and new zealand is a
small subset of that but
those consumers that want to buy it
they prepared to pay
quite favorably for it and if we link
those consumers if we actively target
the ones that want to make the decisions
around their production systems as
opposed to buying stuff say out of
feedlots or out of mass-produced stuff
then we provisioned a program called
taste pure nature that we use globally
and to provision and that's backed up by
sustainability stories where first time
in our history is uh sector we've had
what we call the new zealand farm
assurance program which you have to be
part of new zealand farm assurance
program which validates all your
sustainability metrics to be part of the
taste bureau nature program and we are
building on that with what we call the
nzfap plus now
so that is how we have planned to
increase the value linked to our story
or link to the production systems that
are quite unique to us in new zealand
so andrew just uh an observation and a
question i guess um
i'm i'm really encouraged by the message
you've given us today uh and the
forward-looking um
nature that uh the beef and lamb are
taking to uh the opportunities that are
out there and they are definitely out
there i use there's a i hear a fair bit
of noise being made in the primary
sector at the moment and most of it is
um
is not the sort of things that that
you're saying
and it's a very negative message i i
guess
as someone that's on the front line and
having to deal with that sort of thing
all the time but
what's the plan
is there a plan is it just a continual
getting the information out and hoping
people understand
because there does seem to be quite a
hit of steam being
being generated
and when the opportunities are there as
you've pointed out
i'd hate to see us as a nation
let alone us as a district or as a
province miss out on those opportunities
that
um may go betting big
yeah look i think it's a great question
because
um in in any like look
i was talking to you before the meeting
mia and you said look you've never been
involved in a period where there's been
so much change going on
now and when any of us are in a period
where there's so much change going on
it's hard to absorb all that change and
you either try and suck it up like drink
from the fire hydrant take it all in and
be positive and or sometimes you get
overwhelmed and the sections of our
community in all aspects that are
getting overwhelmed and that's a hundred
percent understandable
and it's a hundred percent appropriate
to work out how you're going to do
because look there's nothing wrong with
saying look this is just too much this
is too fast this is you've just gone too
far there's nothing wrong with having
those conversations
what you've got to work out there we're
quite open at beef and land we're a
solutions based organisation you know
because whenever you're faced with a
problem
anyone can articulate the problem
the challenge becomes in articulating
the solution doesn't it
and that's the challenge that we have
not unlike the protests we saw in
wellington yesterday you know in um what
was we might have seen let's say we saw
1500 people protesting meanwhile we've
got getting close to 90 of new zealand's
vaccinated any of these conversations
you've got to work out whether you
listen to the noise or you listen to
what's actually going on
so i want to put that into context it's
appropriate to be concerned about the
pace of change it's appropriate to voice
that sometimes then you've got to work
out what you're going to do about that
good luck
yep
uh councillor dixon
i have one quick question thank you mr
chair um synthetic meats is
is that going to be an issue into the
future and how do you counter that
so we commissioned a study you know it's
like any of these things we quite often
take a beating from people that think we
well why would you do a study on region
agriculture or why would you do a study
on alternative proteins it's like you're
endorsing it the answer is no
whenever you see a problem arising you
get close to it you try and understand
what it is so we commissioned a study i
think it was back 2017.
look um alternative proteins are coming
and they uh this plant-based alternative
proteins in this cell
cell cellular-based alternative proteins
okay now everything you do globally has
a footprint and so if you're going to
harvest chickpeas lupins sawyers making
possible burgers everything has a
footprint so you just have to report on
that footprint
and so that's why it's really really
important that we get our sustainability
metrics around the the greenhouse gases
appropriate
so look don't be scared of change what
we've said is look we just have to be
quite clear on the consumers that we are
targeting
like i referenced earlier in the day
my concerns around water security i also
have concerns that in our lifetime we
may experience food security issues
globally
you could
form quite a plausible argument that any
form of protein produced under any
system you know appropriate system
actually may alleviate those food
security issues
so just work out how you're going to
provision your product what you're going
to do about it and just have the metrics
right to support your claims
okay no further questions or discussion
from the floor
well thanks andrew for that obviously um
a lot of information has been passed
there and
quietly digest it and work through it
i think probably
we are lucky to have the uh like as one
of our
um personally you're
standing come along and discuss
particularly some of the higher level um
i think if we drag down some of those
points into our local system and realize
the the the actual
um
the or the reliance that we place on the
primary industry particularly in the
current
uh national landscape
um it's it's really kept it has kept us
going kept uh kept the uh the world took
me along and probably a couple of things
i've taken out of that is this
sustainability you've used that word a
number of times sustainable
sustainability and that's probably one
of the big things about the gore
uh gore district or the greater district
that
you know we're trying to create through
some of the developments and various
projects that we have and
um that it's sustainable and that it's a
great as you say a great place to live
and and work and also produce and we we
do have um
some very very uh um
favorable assets particularly around
climate and climate change which in the
future will be seen as an asset so we do
need to look at that water storage and
banking and what we're producing and
that sort of thing so but um thank you
for your time i appreciate that and if
we just move that andrew's report's been
received
uh councillor dixon seconded by
counselor reid
thank you andrew thank you for having me
and i'll have to be rude and shoot off
because i have to do another thing but
thank you very much really appreciate it
and as i say i love the district and
love your that you are you know looking
at opportunities as we go forward so
happy to be part of that anytime you
want to have a chance
cool thank you
okay a second uh item on the agenda is
obviously the gore high school
redevelopment and i see we have a
director um
john mckinley down there
um he's obviously going to give us a
report
or
speak to us about the redevelopment
we've obviously seen some of it in the
media and in various articles and
just with the work that you've been
doing with the ministry and uh what the
plan is going forward now do we need to
start something
okay so we're just going to work off
obviously the other counselors the
information that we've got
in front of us so the floor is yours
john's and welcome
cure mr chairman and counselor thank you
very much
um right i've got a couple of wee points
to go through here and then perhaps you
can ask questions and we'll go from
there if that's okay
so first of all is the state of the
current buildings and you didn't get
this little diagram but it's quite
colorful
and you'll see a lot of orange on that
diagram that's that's the gorham
buildings that are in poor condition
the yellow is fair condition
and the green is good
so by the look of that you'll see that
the
place isn't too good it was built a long
time ago it's in the oldest 18 of school
buildings in the country and a lot of
those will be single level ones whereas
we're double story as well so that's the
first thing
the second thing is that we went through
quite an analysis with the ministry who
started on option one and tried to try
to get us through to agreeing to that
and we managed to push them through to
an option called option four
out of five so the document they
presented to us had five options we
managed to get through to option four
so we thought that was good to start
with
um there's going to be a lot of
demolition
so there'll be about 60 per cent of the
current buildings will be demolished
for those of you that know the school
quite well and many of you probably do
the old d block
c block b block library music suite
they'll all be demolished in some new
buildings in their place
so it's quite exciting really some of
the new buildings one of the new
buildings will be for art
arts rather so it'll be for drama and
music and kappahaka and performing arts
of any kind because we haven't had a
real home for drama for some years we've
had a nice little music suite but it's a
leaky building
it works for us well inside but it leaks
quite a lot and we have to do something
about it so we're aiming to build a
thing called a black box theater that'll
be multi-use
for that purpose so it'll be a sort of
story and a half because it'll have a
high ceiling it'll have permanent setup
but for doing that sort of stuff it'll
only be about 130 square meters that'll
be a place where kids can rehearse and
do little performances and group work
together in all of those disciplines so
that's one of the new buildings we'll be
getting we'll also be getting another
double story block
a new double story block roughly where
the d block is now
and that'll have about 12 or so new
classrooms in it and we'll have to fit
in technology and science and so on into
that too
the library will be incorporated into
there so the library the vision we have
for the library is that it'll be very
much a use all the time space and not a
place you take a class to and then you
take a class back from it'll be
hopefully a bit of a hub
so that's the kind of vision we have for
that
one block i didn't mention was the
technology block if you've ever been in
the air you'll realize we're very lucky
to have a great set of workshops that's
a leaky building as well but we're going
to be keeping that and it'll be repaired
and be refurbished so it's part of the
project as well
we'll have to we'll have to fit into a
smaller footprint one of the things that
the ministry is trying to achieve is get
us down to the size of the role of the
school today so that's called
rationalization and we are well
oversized for that because the school
was very large everybody reminds me how
many kids were there in the 80s
um but it's not that way anymore so
that'll have to change
the thing we're looking forward to the
most is the flexibility and that's about
curriculum and teaching it's so so to me
this whole thing is not really so much
about buildings as it is about
curriculum
um because we teach and we use buildings
in different ways and i said to someone
the other day it's about you know if
people were living in a 1950s bungalow
you know they built them and
didn't matter the lounge was always to
the street whether it was the south or
the east or wherever it was the lounge
was to the street there was a separate
little kitchen you were supposed to go
in there and make the meal and then come
out it was a separate place to eat and
so on and so forth and we don't live
that way anymore and we don't teach and
live that way in schools anymore so we
need a much more flexible usable space
and that's what we're looking forward to
doing
in that regard it's about it's about
integrating the curriculum more so we
expect to see a lot less boundaries so
if you walk into some of the new spaces
um you won't be able to look and say oh
there's the english department or
there's the geography department or
you might be able to say there's the
science department because you'll see
some practical facilities but a lot of
the time it'll be just spaces that we
all use and mingle in and out of and
kids will move between subjects a lot
this a lot more seamlessly than they do
now
we're trialling some of that work now
we're trialling that in year nine right
right this year for example so we're
following a model that we did
um
the following model that we did with
technology so with technology we
trialled some stuff starting about five
years ago we gradually got better and
better at it as more staff had capacity
and then last year when covert hit we
were up and running really fast we were
already in the cloud already pretty
fully technically on so we're doing that
with this curriculum stuff too so that
by the time the new buildings are here
we're kind of ready to use them in that
new way
for example we've got some year nine
classes working together as a instead of
having science and math separately
they're doing them together and they're
doing a unit on forensics and then they
did a unit on crystals and one on
climate change and they're doing things
on the next big shape whether it's an
earthquake or whether it's or whether
it's a volcano and so on and so forth so
they're changing the way mixing it up
the way we're doing our work so it's
really about that
the the design work where we are we're
again there's a diagram here you won't
be able to read it as five steps through
through it we're three fifths of the way
through that now
so with the ministry in terms of this
project we've already tipped off numbers
one two and three
we're starting the design work which is
out here at four so it's taken three
years to get that far
but that's where we're at now
we expect the design work to take about
12 to 18 months and it's starting
we i took a group of architects and
quantity surveyors through last week
we're expecting to go to christchurch at
the end of this month and they'll be
choosing the lead design teams and all
those sorts of things
and then next year we'll be doing the
design planning
i think it'll be 2023 before there's
wrecking balls on the site
and it'll probably be 2025 before it's
all done
and what we're trying to do is get it
ready for the next 40 to 50 years
that's their right
thank you john
i'll open the
floor up to questions
or discussions regarding that um
probably the counsellors first
worship
yeah oh just some observations john
time seems to move incredibly fast
sometimes when you're looking backwards
you're talking about demolishing the
library block i can remember being at
school when the lock block was built
and it doesn't seem that long ago but i
guess it i guess it was
and look it's great to see that
there's new ideas being incorporated
into
uh what is what is planned
uh
i guess one of the questions
i want to ask and i don't know whether
you've got an answer to it you probably
haven't at this point but
not so much about the physical state of
the
of the school going forward but
so
the makeup of education in
in our community
uh and and i know there was some
consultation
between gore high and longford with the
relevant communities about what the
future of that might be i just want if
you can give us a bit of an update on
what that came out with and
does it point in any direction between
a continuation of the separate campuses
or
does it look towards perhaps sharing
campuses
i can talk that to that a little bit so
we did a big report i've got it here
that that gabriel walls came down and
did and the outcome of that report was
there was quite a lot of
support within the community to put the
two to schools together not as two
schools on one campus though as a new
kind of model was really where the
support was people didn't see any real
need to just shift one school and put on
another piece of grass
so that wasn't what we were thinking
about there's quite a bit of support for
that our boards are still working
through that and um
many of us would like that to have gone
a bit faster but it's still they're
still working through it and i think
it's still positive in its intent at the
moment but there's no final decision
reached okay however the the
the the driver for that really was this
curriculum again because we think that
we can if we can start them at year
seven and take them right through
we think and and longford staff we've
talked to them a lot about this too and
we've visited some schools in auckland
where this was happening we think we can
design a year seven to nine or seven to
ten curriculum where kids can have a lot
more of an interesting time and be a lot
more challenged there's no reason for
example why a year seven kid has to take
one year in year seven and then one year
in year eight in one year in year nine
there's no reason why you couldn't have
somebody in year seven working on
somebody and you're nine on a module of
work for three months and then with new
changes and choices they are working
with a different group of children so
there's no reason why it can't be quite
a different model
and it's that kind of thing we're
interested in and i think the the idea
of bringing the two schools together is
still a possibility
but it's not decided yet right so um
just thinking ahead you know should that
ever happen
uh is the is the construction that's
planned for the new ho ho uh gorhai
campus
is it gonna be
relevant and
compatible with the numbers of people
that were likely to become yeah
so
ideally
the decision
as to whether longford and gore high
school want to get together or not would
come in the next few months ideally okay
if that happened then
as we go into the detailed design we can
keep that in mind straight away
if that doesn't happen
the design work we've done so far which
is really just conceptual has got places
where we can add to a block or put it
you know rather than put a new block
actually extend the block a little bit
further which would then accommodate
that kind of
issue
okay
and a third question that
it's not really related to the
construction of the building but um
the the use of the the property in total
and i know this is the fence been gone
along uh part of the sports field and
what have you and you've got the sports
fields across the road um
is is that still
what's happening with that at the moment
the the um the coots road feel we call
it i mean they're both on coots road i
don't know why they call it one good
throw the one over by frank street
anyway up along there there's no no
plans to change that that's still going
to be a sports field as such the other
side the memorial gates will stay with
with the current school property and
there's a fence you might notice on the
east of that
the property on the east of that is now
owned by the ministry and they should be
disposing of that it should be going
through their disposals process right
okay
that's good thanks
now councillor reed thank you mr chair
so john when you're saying it's going
through a
disposal process does that have to go
back to um
to see whether or not they have a need
for it before it's disposed of yes i
understand so i think i think if the if
the land was gifted to the school in the
first place it has to be often back
there
then it has to be offered to local uni
and then the next step would be to
whoever was based
and back to the floor plan that we have
at the school in front of us
[Music]
technically even if it takes a wee while
to
have longford come on site or not
there's still plenty of room there for
expansion isn't it
yes there is um
so
and they've got a couple of future
expansion sort of
um lines built in there so i think that
we're well endowed with land aren't we
yes we're very lucky so i think that it
could easily be expanded like for
example our learning support
area where we have
my plan my my
dream would be to shift that as well and
to put it over near robertson street
where it's a lot more accessible for
parents coming in with their children
being able to drop them off on our
property instead of on the street
and drive out again and so on and and it
would be nice and near the new library
and near where there's a lot of flow it
wouldn't be sort of tucked on the end of
a building would be on the end of a
building but not sort of out it's on its
own so there's kind of things like that
that
i've given up yet there's a few more
things we'd like to try and get
and just one other question um because
that land is there
is there any possibility in the future
like we had that discussion through the
streets live program
um
dirty word but there you go um
to be able to have a bus hub on that a
way so that takes the kids off the
street i'd be really
keen to see something like that so it's
a much more
uh safe environment for children to be
delivered and then picked up yeah i
think
um originally i thought that could be
done quite easily really just build us a
new school further over and put a bus up
around the entire corner but the
ministry didn't fly for that um so
that's a wee bit harder now because
we've got to relocate our horticulture
area that'll take up a bit of the land
where the old hostel was
where you might have thought of the
buses made coming in so that's a wee bit
harder now than it was
dennis thank you mr chair
um
thank you for that john it looks
exciting
um just what i see you've got car
parking is that going to try and take
some of the students cars off the street
or is that more for
the staff it depends who gets there the
earliest
i think it's probably supposed to be for
staff and for parents coming as visitors
and for visitors
any other questions here from the
councillors discussion
um thank you john obviously uh
that was
interesting there was a few blocks that
you mentioned in there and i'm a bit
like tracy uh there's a couple of those
blocks there that i actually remember
with pain
probably due to some of the corporal
punishment that used to come out in the
in my day there so but
i had a couple of questions
um the
the current role what's the current role
of the school number wise yeah it's a
bit under 500 we started this year about
485 or something like that predicting
just slightly less than that next year
that's mainly because there are a
slightly smaller group coming through
from longford intermediate so that
affects us a lot
and after that it's supposed to steady
up and come up a bit
it's very hard to predict those and i
always get frustrated that the
ministry
tend to use
i suppose they try and use census data
but they don't tend to forward think any
other opportunities that are happening
in the district so they don't think
about forward employment opportunities
or industries that are starting to
flourish and gore district they just go
on the numbers they've got now so it's a
bit of a hard argument for us to fight
sometime
and obviously the census data that it
works on um we're a bit marginal anyway
with the
previous sense of starter and what could
be coming
um
just in regard to that you've obviously
got the partnership through there with
ewe and the the
rooney
is the other uh within the school
cultural diversity like with the groups
because we're seeing it within the
community strategy like the work that
the team have been doing um there's a
huge you know quite a huge melting pot
of different cultures currently within
the ghoul area do you see that through
the school with some of the groups and
yeah there's little wee pockets of it
but we don't have any great lot of
children in any one particular diverse
community
so
we do have a few
we have a few pacifica for example a few
filipino
some other asian cultures but it's very
limited really
so it's mostly for us about 17 maori
that's the big one for us and
there's quite a lot of work going on
through not only um wanting to make this
building reflect our culture
um but there's also quite a lot of work
going on nca with in terms of matarama
maori and valuing maori knowledge and
maori ways of learning so
that's probably the big push
is is that a um
or the model that you're following is it
currently being used in another like are
you looking at another school round was
the ministry sort of have a model school
around the countryside or is it
something that you adapt to the area
yeah they don't have a model school that
i'm aware of we have looked at various
schools um
we looked at one in australia we've
looked at several in auckland some in
hamilton looked at christchurch and we
know a bit about our own district looked
at a few there
so the the one we have seen the most in
terms of curriculum that we like is one
in auckland
and
its curriculum would not just transpose
into gore it's just it's giving us ideas
and we have to design our own and make
it fit our community
we're a fairly unique community and i
don't think the auckland template would
be put across gore easily so
um
is there any others just a question
around the arts block that you're
talking about john
um will that encompass performing arts
yeah so so black box theater um does
anyone know what a black box there is am
i talking to people right so let's say a
room about maybe two thirds the size so
let's say same length maybe about
two-thirds of it right and um flat floor
no risers you bring those in when you
need them
completely black black walls black
ceiling permanent lighting and down one
end would be a u-shaped curtain
so if a little drama group wants to do a
production they get into that curtain
area a few seats at this end maybe ones
that can pull out from the wall 30-40
people can watch watch a little play or
something like that
but equally music groups could use it
dance groups could use it when you're
rehearsing the curtains go back there's
mirrors so they can see what they are
doing et cetera et cetera okay yeah i
was just interested in the potential
size of that and potential for community
use as well but yeah just quite small it
would be reasonably small be lovely to
build it bigger but it wouldn't on on
the ministry's funding we wouldn't
manage it yeah
uh any other discussion there from
councillors
okay
uh thank you john for that update that's
um it's
a big project
and it's a it's a great looking project
and i think if we uh align that with
with our previous uh matter on the
agenda um it's about sustainability and
you sort of indicated that yourself
which one future-proof ourselves the
next 40 50 years
and i think that the southern region is
going to be a desirable place to be yeah
as the the way things are going globally
and i think we'll be we'll be seeing
that in our census data
um if i just have someone move that
director's report's receipt
councillor grant and the secretary
councillor reed
thank you thank you john for your time
okay we move on to
a report the welcome plan report which
uh we've had a copy in the notes there
from our uh community our cec or our
community empowerment coordinator uh
mark so um
it sounds quite official outside isn't
it
thank you mr chair afternoon everyone um
i firstly wanted to reiterate um the
importance of the new core district
welcome plan
as i've said before we have at least 45
different ethnicities in the gore
district
and we're still counting um
that represents about at least eight
percent of the goal district population
according to the last census
um but according to stats new zealand
projections this number is going to
increase
um
and it's important to note that eight
percent does not include people from
wales from the uk
from the us from australia
international students
and new zealanders relocating within new
zealand who are defined as newcomers
within the welcome plan as well
um it was interesting listening to john
just talk about the number of
people from different ethnicities within
the high school
so we spoke to saint peter's college and
the population of overseas born students
there is actually 11
and that didn't include international
students which took that figure then to
14
so quite a high number
um
so
the success of the welcoming communities
pilot scheme which we are a part of um
along with eight other councils
um it's had huge success and has now
extended to 17 councils within the
country which is great news and more and
more are signing on each month
as part of the agreement that we have
with immigration new zealand we need to
produce a welcome plan
for the area
um
this used to be a southland wide plan
but after talking with immigration new
zealand they've encouraged us to tailor
our plan to the gore district which
differs vastly from invercargill for
example
um so the gold district council itself
has through consultation with a
representative group of local people and
newcomers to the google community
embarked on developing a new welcome
plan which is tailored to our needs
it's a community driven
council document
we felt that within the community
strategy team that is that as a council
it needs to be a council document
because we are welcoming these people
and we also felt that they may not be
the capacity for them themselves to
drive the plan because they'll be
working themselves
and it's a five-year plan
to enable us to align it with the next
ltp as well
and the opportunities issues concerns
and opportunities raised by the
representative group are the
underpinning aspects of this new plan
and the plan includes opportunities and
initiatives aimed at raising cultural
awareness
and overcoming barriers to integration
for both the local community and
newcomers
the plan itself is about support
and empowerment
hence the type the new title
for the newcomer community
immigration new zealand themselves have
been very interested in the approach
which we've taken
which reflects the newcomer voices
themselves rather than what we want to
do for them
and they are proposing that we feed
forward this approach to other councils
it's been really well received
and so
moving forward we need permission from
the council
to send out the welcome plan to public
for their feedback
we propose doing that on november 15th
in a couple of days time
and for this feedback to end on november
the 9th before taking it to the
representative working group
which i have to say um had offered to
come here today to support this
um but for obvious reasons couldn't be
here
and
once the working group has gone through
those suggestions we will bring it back
to council
in the new you
any questions
counselor
thank you
congratulations mark i'm very very
impressed with this report
awesome extremely well done and thank
your team as well um i know i was on the
initial one and believe you me we didn't
put it together anywhere near as quickly
as this it took a couple of years plus
and it certainly wasn't as detailed or
as
interesting and particularly as you said
asking
the immigrants themselves the newcomers
themselves to actually participate was a
brilliant stroke i like it
[Music]
i'm really really excited about what
you've done here i think it's brilliant
and um
it's very interesting reading because
one of the things i did notice is that
we do pride ourselves on being friendly
but
maybe we're not that friendly and i
think
as time goes on we're going to have a
lot more um
different ethnicities and different
or new zealanders from different parts
of the country as well coming down so
i think we're onto a good thing here so
thank you
fantastic thank you
if i can just respond to that this has
been very very much a team effort
from ann
coming up with the idea to approach the
newcomer community to get their voice
and them coming on board and really
embracing the process and supporting the
process and
coming forward with some fantastic ideas
and there's lots of opportunities there
there really are so
yeah it's been a real team effort and
i've got to say the um the plan itself
is
it looks great thanks to rebecca and her
hard work
yeah so um thank you
where
fits nicely with averages
thank you i do notice that's one thing
that it's every issue that would be
facing somebody coming to the district
has been covered and i think it's a
really good template for us to take
notice of and and work alongside you
guys to make it
easier to implement
um the international connect group that
and just referred to not only did they
provide the forum for us to carry out
the workshop
that provided newcomers with the
opportunity to share their voice and um
mayor tracy hicks was there as was
the chair um
but that group also will provide
a large amount of the driving force
moving forward a lot of good things come
from that group they've started up new
clubs of their own which are very
inclusive of the local community as well
so we um we really will hit the ground
running with this
yeah
mr i'd just like to endorse the comments
that have been made um
by bronwyn so far
the
the style
the content the whole direction of the
plan
is is absolutely fantastic and i look
forward to seeing what feedback we do
get from the wider community and and
just on that point mark i was going to
ask
how's that going to be circulated how is
how how are people going to know about
this
um so we've been working with sonia and
the comms manager on this and
so it'll go online
as well as through different channels
that i oversee myself and we'll get it
out there as much as possible within the
district both newcomers and local
community
and encourage their feedback they can
contact us directly as well
give their feedback um
yeah we would encourage people to really
have a good read of it and please yeah
give us your thoughts
[Music]
thank you mr chair i think it is a
fantastic reporting um
and i love it and i think it and
embraces everything that we would want
as a council in a district when we're
welcoming people
the only thing i would suggest was maybe
page 45
doesn't look particularly familiar to me
as being a gore district photo looks
more like
some very tall mountains somewhere
right yes yeah no i see your point
no i don't think it's the back face of
the hoku noise
yeah
yeah mark just want to say what everyone
else is saying yeah fantastic report
good reading um plenty of engagement
with the um the new cameras and and
obviously you've met up with them and
they've given you suggestions as well i
did have a wee idea just to try and get
them into the community into the
sporting organizations it's like kind of
like what the um schools do with the um
older kids and they're doing a career
evening and then maybe you could get the
um say the rugby clubs and croquet clubs
and bowling clubs um get people to come
and have a yarn
and then maybe help get some of these
people into these sporting venues yeah
yeah yeah just uh yeah
to take yes we are very nice front on
but yeah deep down it would be good to
get involved with these with newcomers
and um make them really welcomed into
the community absolutely so yeah it is
easy to join them into clubs and you
don't have to go looking if we had them
all in one area for a night for them and
yeah yeah connections that way awesome
yeah yeah great report
and even have a go yeah exactly yes yes
yes and i did like the idea of walking
them around town and um yeah i thought
that was quite neat and yeah i'd be
definitely keen to join the awesome
that'd be great just make conversations
with them and yeah brilliant make them
feel welcome exactly thank you
any further discussion or commentary
there
um yeah i'll just reiterate what
everyone said mark good job done um and
also obviously through to the some of
the people that were contracting and
then doing uh some of the consultant
work there rebecca and that crew they're
doing a marvelous job it's good good um
good bang for buck
to coin that phrase and i think um
that on page 28 of our report if we look
at that page 14
of your plan
a cultural competency the the definition
of it is where two people can actually
stand there and look at each other and
say that phrase you know the ability to
understand appreciate and interact with
people from cultures or beliefs systems
different from one's own
um i think that we've probably got the
cornerstone on the ground
uh in gore now um we are you know we're
doing some great work and making some
inroads there and i think it's it goes
both ways because there's people within
the community are not quite sure what
they're meant to do
um particularly some of our older older
folk or people that haven't had that
travel experience or that interaction
with different cultures and they want to
be involved but they're not quite sure
whether they're gonna
you know put their foot on it or say the
wrong thing or do something that's um
culturally insensitive so um yeah kudos
to that uh so we just need to
um
have someone pass at that report mr
chairman do we want to discuss the photo
for you quite um
i'd like to see that we try and use
local photographs yeah in the report of
possible things okay so i think the
committee would probably like to see it
localized photo
i'm sure you'll be able to uh do that
i'm sure rebecca will
find something there that will fit that
framework
um but uh with that in mind uh if i just
have someone to uh
mr chair before we do that sorry can i
just make one more comment um i said
earlier that the um the working group
would love to have been here to support
this today and i know that they'll be
tuning in so i just wanted to say a big
thank you to them for all their support
and the working group as well moving
forward and thank you
now
obviously the committee would recognise
their efforts as well
we know that we know that you're not
solely leading the charge and you've got
a great a great uh battalion behind you
that's helping out so absolutely um
so with that and obviously that
photographic change um if we just
recommend that so that will go we'll
recommend that that goes out we've got a
short period of time there where it's
placed through the comms and then we'll
get the feedback and it'll come back
through
um the main we'll come through one of
our main council meetings
the feedback goes back to the reference
group and they get to decide what should
go in the plan
and then it will come back to this
community okay and we will document any
changes that we've made
yeah okay so that's a
true community-led process
and with this plan even though
it then sets the work
flow
for this
okay
sounds like a good process
if we just have someone move that
recommendation counselor send it
counselor dixon
um and thank you mark for the support
i think that unless there's any other
general business at the end i didn't
actually ask if there's any late
business or general business but um if
there's nothing else from the floor
the ceo is happy over there that's the
main thing
either way
so at uh
4 50
we'll end the meeting thank you for your
attendance and thank you for your
involvement councillors